il ya un peu plus de deux ans en 2015
david wavre sur son site 90 vous a
présenté une stratégie inverse table au
poker alors poite si c'était un certain
type de poker savoir le texas hold'em
head's up limites en particulier c'était
une version limite du poker ce qui veut
dire que vous n'aviez le droit de mise
et qu'une certaine somme prix déterminé
à l'avancé à chaque relance sa basse à
limite carrément les possibilités de
bluffer mais depuis la vidéo de david
les intelligences artificielles beaucoup
progressé et elles se sont mis au poker
no limit avec succès en particulier
elles ont appris à bluffer et a bien
bluffés ainsi en 2007 libre à tous une
intelligence artificielle créée par des
chercheurs de carnegie mellon university
a réussi à bluffer way freight le monde
du poker
c'est horrible ce casino de pittsburgh
que libre à tous aux à défier quatre des
meilleurs joueurs de poker humain du
monde 200 mille dollars furent mises en
jeu à répartir en fin de compétition
entre les quatre humains en fonction de
leurs gains respectifs contredit prat us
chaque jour pendant trois semaines pour
annuler le facteur chance de me perdre
de joueurs a et b affronter
simultanément libre à tous dans deux
salles totalement séparées et les cartes
donné à un furent données ali bratus
contre b tandis que celle donnée à b
purcell de libre à tous contre à la nuit
à l'instar sans doute des joueurs libres
at us méditer les parties qu'il avait
perdu le jour pour toujours mieux
s'adapter à ses adversaires
après 120 mille mains jouées le résultat
fut sans appel
libra tu as fait détruit les joueurs
humains en effet libre at us a gagné en
moyenne 14
cette big blind toutes les cendres et ça
pour ceux qui connaissent le poker c'est
une mousse tre sayeh titres air les
médias les ja sont désormais meilleures
que nous pour bluffer
en effet la performance de libre à tous
est loin d'être anodine à l'instar des
vrais jeux qui nous concerne dans la vie
quotidienne
le poker est un jeu à informations
incomplètes ça veut dire qu'à tout
moment on ne sait pas ce qu'il faut
faire
non seulement parce qu'on ne sait pas
comment l'autre balle gier mais aussi
parce qu'il ya de l'information qui nous
est manquante typiquement dans le cas du
poker on ne connaît pas les cartes que
l'autre a en main et ça ça contraste pas
mal avec tous les jeux dont on a parlé
jusque là ottoman dans l'épisode
précédent où toute l'information et
publics y compris dans le jeu
go dont on a parlé dans un épisode
précédent et dont david et thomas vous
ont parlé sur leurs chaînes respectives
en particulier dans les jeux
séquentielle informations complètes
typiquement comme les échecs ou le jeu
de go toute l'information pertinente un
instant donné et connue est la meilleure
stratégie dépend uniquement de cette
information publique on parle d'
équilibre de nage ans ou jeu parfait
vous souvenez du coup en particulier les
joueurs d'échecs vont s'attarder à
étudier les and games c'est à dire les
configurations de fin de jeu où il faut
tibi comment réussir à faire échec et
mat
en trois coups cependant pour le poker
toute l'information publique ne suffit
pas à deviner les cartes de l'adversaire
ni même à deviner quelles sont les
cartes probable de l'adversaire puisque
les cartes probable de l'adversaire
dépendons aussi et surtout de la manière
dont l'adversaire joue en effet
imaginons que l'on ait une paire d'as et
que l'adversaire fait tapis c'est à dire
qui mise tout son argent
faut-il de suivre et miser un autre tour
tout notre argent vous voulez bien que
certes le fait qu'il ait misé autant
d'argent à ce tour ci est peut être
miser beaucoup dans le tour précédent
est une information pertinente pour
essayer de deviner quelles sont les
cartes qu'ils en ont mais cela n'est
qu'une information partielle sur les
cartes qu'il a vraiment en main et du
coup on peut pas s'entraîner à faire
handy games pire encore pour bien
deviner quelles sont les cartes qu'il a
en main à ce moment là il est aussi et
surtout important de savoir comment cet
adversaire joue en général dans des
mains typique
autrement dit pour bien jouer au poker
surtout dans le poker no limit
il faut non seulement penser à la main
qui est en train d'être joué mais aussi
à toutes les mains précédentes et plus
généralement à tous les déroulements
possible d'une main de poker et en
particulier on ne peut donc pas se
restreindre à l'information publique sur
la main en jeu comme on pourrait le
faire dans les jeux informations
complètes comme les chèques ou le jeu de
go mais il ya plus intéressant encore
pour bien jouer au poker il faut aussi
et surtout que l'adversaire soit
incapable de deviner quelles sont les
cartes que l'on a en main et ça ça veut
dire que la meilleure chose que l'on a
affaire à un instant donné dépend aussi
fortement de la manière dont on vous ré
d'autres mains potentiel ainsi la
stratégie au poker comme dans l'art du
bluff en général se doit d'être une
stratégie globale de sortie
oui les pistes et empêcher l'adversaire
de nous lire au moment du bluff en
particulier même quand on ne bluffe pas
il faut essayer de jouer comme si on le
fait pour pouvoir préparer le cas où on
va effectivement bluffé or à l'instar
des échecs ou du jeu de go le poker est
un jeu incroyablement combinat taurian
surtout au poker no limit ou le nombre
d'aidés roman possible d'une partie est
beaucoup plus grand que le nombre de
particules dans l'univers sachant qu'une
bonne stratégie au poker se doit de
coordonner tous les déroulements
possible d'une main de poker qui soient
des bluffs ou non sens que c'est pas
facile à résoudre le poker semble tout
simplement impossible et c'est pour ça
que les ja ont longtemps galéré face aux
humains et que leurs capacités
surhumaines au poker ne sont venues
qu'après leurs capacités surhumaines au
jeu de go est d'ailleurs contrairement à
ces fusent pour le heads up limites dont
david vous apparaît dans cette vidéo
libre at us n'a pas résolu le poker no
limit en particulier tout comme il n'est
pas impossible qu'un humain finissent
par batral fagots il n'est pas
impossible qu'un humain finissent par
battre libre à tous ceux ci perso je
vous déconseille de vous mettre à la
même table que libre à tuchan tout comme
il aura été aussi concevable que libre à
tu sois en fait battu par une autre
intelligence artificielle x que xo battu
par y est que y bat libre à tous même si
bon pour l'instant il semble que libre
at us soit vainqueur de condorcet dans
le sens où il semble battre tout autre
joueur humain ou intelligence
artificielle et pourquoi il ya une
énorme différence entre le poker les
mines qu'est le poker no limit à savoir
pour le poker limite n'y a finalement
que 10 puissance 14 déroulement possible
d'une main et 10 puissance 14 c'est
beaucoup mais c'est pas insurmontable
pour les supercalculateurs d'aujourd'hui
après tout ça ne représente que quelques
milliers de téraoctets il est donc
possible de simuler tous les
déroulements possible du poker imite un
grand nombre de fois mais le cas du no
limit est tout autre puisque le nombre
des déroulements possible est de l'ordre
de 10 puissance 165
autrement dit ne simulait qu'une seule
fois ne serait ce qu'une infime fraction
de tous les déroulements possible avec
tous les supercalculateurs que l'on a
aujourd'hui prendrait un temps bien plus
grand que l'âge de l'univers pour le no
limit il est illusoire d'espérer avoir
une stratégie imbattable et du coup au
lieu d'essayer de s'approcher d'une
stratégie imbattable il est préférable
de s'adapter à l'adversaire avant que
celui-ci de s'adapte à nous autre
remarque intéressante mais
c'est fusent qu'il ne stratégie
imbattable n'est pas forcément la
meilleure stratégie contre un humain et
oui parce que tout ce qu'on sait sur ces
faits us sait que contraindre humains au
poker limites qui appartenait
suffisamment longue
ces foetus ne perdra pas mais si vous
avez déjà participé à un tournoi de
poker vous savez sans doute que ne pas
perdre ne suffit pas il faut constamment
essayé de gagner de l'argent ce qui
revient à exploiter les faiblesses des
adversaires alors si vous jouez au poker
vous savez sans doute qu'une meilleure
stratégie contre des débutants n'est pas
forcément la même que la meilleure
stratégie contre des experts typiquement
les débutants sur joue souvent des
mauvaises mains ils ont tendance à
suivre
du coup ce que je fais contre débutants
c'est que je ne mise gros que lorsque
j'ai un très gros jeu et surtout contre
des débutants et j'évite de bluffer avec
des mauvaises mains parce qu'on sait
jamais peut-être suivre même si l'on est
mauvais joueur et sa basse et fut aussi
sait pas faire c'est fait c'est une
stratégie statique qui ne s'adapte pas à
son adversaire
enfin pour faire le tour du monde du
poker il me faut absolument parler du
cas où on n'est pas en red the job c'est
quand on est un contre un parce que le
vrai poker c'est sur notre plutôt le
texas hold'em no limit où il ya
plusieurs personnes autour de la table
et l'analyse du poker est beaucoup plus
complexe en fait il n'est même pas
garantie qu'il existe une stratégie
regrettable est possible que peu importe
votre stratégie
les autres joueurs autour de la table
peuvent concevoir une autre stratégie
qui vous fera perdre de toute façon mais
surtout dans une vraie partie de poker
il faut réussir à détecter rapidement
quels sont les joueurs les plus faibles
autour de la table et leur extorquer
l'argent aussi vite que possible en
particulier ça veut dire qu'il faut
apprendre en temps réel la manière dont
les autres joueurs à la table joue ça
c'est super super super difficile et on
peut dire que c'est un domaine de
recherche encore largement ouvert et
très mal compris pire encore dans une
vraie partie de poker il faut prendre en
compte les nombre de jetons des autres
joueurs autour de la table sachant que
le joueur qui a le plus de jetons va
avoir tendance à être plus agressif
alors qu'un joueur avec peu de jetons va
souvent joué de façon très serrée et
attendre le bon moment pour tout miser
enfin dans le vrai poker la stratégie
optimale diffère selon l'objectif que
l'on se fixe le but peut être de
maximiser la probabilité de finir
premier ou ça peut être de maximiser la
probabilité tête dans les trois premiers
où ça peut être de maximiser l'espérance
de gain la fin de la partie
dans tous ces cas la stratégie optimale
est différente
comme tout joueur qui hésitent à faire
tapis lorsqu'il ne reste que quatre
joueurs
le sait bref tout ça pour dire que
développer une intelligence artificielle
qui brille au vrai poker est encore plus
dur que ce qu'on réussisse effet us est
libre à tous or le vrai poker n'est
encore qu'une version extrêmement
simplifiée des interactions humaines
notamment des jeux de pouvoir et oui
parce que non seulement dans les jeux de
pouvoir l'information est toujours très
incomplète mais en plus il faut
constamment cherché à faire des
coalitions pour réussir à gagner ce
n'est donc pas étonnant que la quasi
totalité d'entre nous soient incapables
de comprendre tous les jeux de la
politique et que des modèles plus
formalisées comme ceux de mesquita s'en
sortent mieux que nos intuitions
dernière fois je vous ai présenté un top
10 de la théorie des jeux et on a parlé
notamment du truel dès le 10 juillet où
ali charlie et bob devait se tirer les
uns sur les autres et bluesy cornes fait
remarquer qu'il ya un épisode de numbers
qui parle d'un truelle dans son joueur
alors je vous propose d'écouter
un trader fait c'est pas tout à fait la
bonne réponse fait pas du tout la bonne
réponse qu'il fallait donner
en effet comme beaucoup nous fait
remarquer si alice essaie de tuer bob si
jamais elle réussit à toucher bob elle
se fait tuer immédiatement après du coup
passé un petit peu c'est un petit peu
bête comme stratégie 1 vaut mieux ici de
tirer sur charlie dès le premier et bien
en fait c'est pas forcément ça sa
meilleure stratégie à liszt en fait
comme c'est écrit dans le blog des
vigiles la meilleure stratégie en tout
cas dans le cas où alice a une chance
sur trois de toucher sa cible et bob a
une chance sur deux de toucher sa cible
la meilleure stratégie pour alice c'est
de tirer en l'air et de ne viser
personne
plusieurs parmi vous qui ont essayé à
trouver cette bonne réponse à adobe de
boxe par contre j'ai pas vu énormément
de calcul bien rigoureux malheureusement
dans les commentaires peut-être que j'en
ai loupé beaucoup de commentaires j'ai
pas tout passé au peigne fin
donc ce que vous propose c'est qu'on
s'attarde un tout petit peu dans
lesquels que nécessaire donc supposons
que alice a une probabilité à de toucher
sa cible bob une croix stb et charlier
en profiter c'est en fait si on a un
duel entre paix et qu et sip et tire en
premier avec un petit raisonnement dont
je vous passe un petit peu les détails
on voit que la priorité que p gagne le
duel face à qu est égale ap / p
puisqu'une - pq alors que la preuve
était que q games
c'est un - p fois qu / le même
dénominateur n'est fait pour que tu
gagnes il faut que b est raté et
qu'ensuite qu est touché et si jamais
les deux ratés on se retrouve au cas
initial moi c'est pour ça qu'elle est le
dénominateur passe je passe encore une
fois un peu sous silence les détails
donc en particules on voit que si alice
tout charlie alors la probabilité
qu'elle gagne ce sera 1 - b fois à
diviser par a plus b - 1 b alors que si
elle touche
bob la probabilité qu'elle gagne ensuite
en duel contre charlie sachant que
charlie tirs en première
du coup ce sera égal à cette quantité là
et lorsque c'est égal à lorsque j'ai
toujours sa cible bas on voit que alice
perd forcément du coup haïtien aucun
intérêt à viser
bob puisque si jamais le toucher est sûr
de perdre ils vont encore mieux pour
elle de tirer en l'air et en fait ça
c'est peut-être le cas en fête pour tous
les tireurs tous les membres de ce
truelle effet imaginons le cas limite où
tout le monde en fait très très bon et
en fait une probabilité égale à 1 de
toucher sa cible
si alice tiers sur bob ou charlie à ce
moment là est sûr de toucher sa cible et
du coup elle fera tomber l'un de ses
rivaux mais elle se retrouvera en duel
avec quelqu'un qui a une priorité 1 de
la toucher du coup cette autre personne
va forcément tirer et alice va perdre
mais maintenant ce raisonnement on peut
le faire aussi à passe de bob si tout le
monde a une premier terrain de touche
les autres
bob c'est que si jamais ils touchent une
de ses cibles alors il se fera tuer
juste après et chari peut faire le même
raisonnement
en fait dans le cas où tous les tireurs
sont excellents aucun intérêt à tirer
puisque en en tirant il est sûr de
perdre une solution de ce trail c'est
simplement que personne ne tire ça c'est
le cas dans mon parti que lorsque tout
le monde est très bon mais c'est aussi
le cas lorsque les gens ne veulent
vraiment pas mourir parce qu'en fait si
on regarde bien ce jeu il ya trois
issues possibles soit on gagne dans ce
sens on est le dernier survivant
soit on se fait tuer soit bas personne
ne tire sur quiconque et on reste vive
en mai
on n'est pas le dernier à survivre
puisque les deux autres sont encore en
vie et à ce moment là le combat
s'éternise n'a donc trois issues
possibles de ce jeu est ce que je n'ai
pas précisé dans la vidéo précédente
c'est assez à quel point les différents
joueurs valu les différentes issues
possibles
alors bien sûr les gens préfèrent être
vainqueur à être le dernier survivant
être le seul survivant
bien sûr les gens ne veulent pas mourir
mais on ne sait pas à quel point ils
sont prêts à risquer leur vie à risque
et le fait de mourir pour pouvoir être
le seul vainqueur de ce truand et donc
si on veut complètement résoudre ce
problème il nous faut absolument un
goûter une donnée à savoir l'utilité
d'une personne qui ne gagne pas mais ne
perd pas non plus alors tout ça ça
complique énormément l'analyse et donc
il est possible que même si lorsque les
tireurs ont une probabilité qui n'est
pas égale à 1 de toucher leurs cibles en
fonction de leurs préférences par
rapport au fait de ne pas mourir si on
particules mourir ça correspond une
utilité - fini bas les gens vont pas
trop risqué de tirer et à ce moment là
l'équipe de nage peut tout simplement
être le cas où personne ne tient
et ça ça explique pourquoi les duels des
westerns sont toujours aussi longs tout
cas s'il y avait trois personnes en jeu
vraiment vrai duel de western dance qui
est trois personnes ça va être super bon
puisque ça n'a intérêt à tirer
bon ça explique pas pourquoi les duels
dans les westerns sont aussi longs c'est
un truc que j'ai jamais compris ça
supposons maintenant pour simplifier que
l'un des tireurs et prêt à tirer
et donc si on a un qui est prêt à tirer
au moins la personne sur laquelle elle
est prête à tirer va vouloir tirer à son
histoire et à ce moment là bas on a au
moins deux personnes qui veulent tirer
or pour simplifier on peut supposer que
la personne qui a le plus grande
probabilité de toucher sa cible jeou
charlie et du coup de façon stratégique
charlie a intérêt à tirer sur la
personne qui est la deuxième meilleure
aux tirs si alice est meilleur que bob
aux tirs
alice alors tout intérêt à tirer sur
charlie puisque sinon on va se faire
buter par charlie du coup la stratégie
optimale des listes 6
ah les meilleurs que bob pour tirer et
si charlie est meilleur que bob pour
tirer c'est de tirer sur schering
maintenant faisons un petit peu plus
sophistiquée supposons que ce soit bob
qui soit le deuxième meilleur tir a du
coup à l'iss et à la moins bonne des
tireuses à ce moment-là alice a tout
intérêt à tirer sur charlie plutôt que
bob mais comme beaucoup d'entre vous
l'ont fait remarquer dans les
commentaires alice pas aussi simplement
tiré en l'air être sûr d'en rater sa
cible et attendre que les deux autres
s'entretuent en tout cas que l'un des
deux autres tu l'autre à ce moment-là
alice aura la main ce sera à elle de
tirer et elle pourra tirer sur la
personne restantes
alors faisons un petit peu plus ses
calculs tu poses oncle charlie tire
mieux que baup à ce moment alice n'a
clairement pas interdit assure bob est
plutôt sur charlie que sur bob et sa
probabilité de gagner en duel si elle
arrive à tuer charlie contre bob sera
comme bob dire en premier la priorité
qu'elle gagne à ce moment là sera un - b
x a des visées par a plus b - at-c
maintenant supposons que alice dire en
l'air qui nous touche pas sa cible
à ce moment là c'est à bob de tirer et
bob va devoir tirer sur charlie parce
que sinon c'est charlie qui va tirer sur
bob du coup bob a tout intérêt à essayer
de tirer sur charlie et si bob arrive à
toucher sa cible alors à il se
retrouvera en duel contre bob mais cette
fois alice aura la priorité puisque ce
sera à elle de tirer à ce moment-là
profité que alice gagne contre bob en
duel sera cette quantité là si beau brad
maintenant alors charlie sachant que bob
est meilleure qu'elle il soutire a tout
intérêt à tirer sur bob et si charlie
toucha cible alors ali se retrouve en
duel contre charlie avec la priorité
c'est réaliste tir à ce moment là et
après été que alice bat charlie en duel
c'est cette quantité l'aaa / à puce et -
at-c alors maintenant la probabilité que
alice gagne sachant qu'il va avoir un
duel entre les deux autres et que l'un
des deux autres cols mourir en
particulier le cas si ice tire toujours
en l'air tant que les deux autres sont
encore vivants à ce moment là la
probabilité que alice gagne en tirant
toujours en l'air lorsque les deux
autres sont encore vivants
ça va être une moyenne pondérée des deux
organes qui des petites astuces de
calculs que je passe sous silence mais
on obtient cette formule là qui est
formule un peu compliqué mais qui permet
de calculer exactement la probabilité
que alice gagne sachant qu'ils attirent
toujours en l'air comme bob qui errent
toujours sur charlie et que charrie dire
toujours sur pop avec ces deux formules
on peut enfin répondre à la question est
ce qu'alice a intérêt à tirer en l'air
ou à essayer de tirer sur charlie parce
que j'arrivais pardon trop fort et bien
ça dépend de ces deux quantités là en
fait elle va avoir intérêt à tirer
directement sur charlie si la paire
quantité ici la probabilité qu'elle
gagne en duel contre bob sachant que bob
à la priorité est plus grande que cette
quantité ici un peu et n'a donc là c'est
un petit peu abstrait ça fait beaucoup
de formules donc si on réduit tout ça
les équations on obtient priori or si je
me suis pas trompé dans ses calculs en
s'est pas dit que j'ai pas fait
d'erreurs de calcul on devra obtenir
cette quantité a donc en gros à lise
intérêt à tirer sur charlie six as et
après était qu'elle tire bien est
inférieur ou égal à cette quantité l'aïe
qui dépend des premiers tp et c'est mon
bob et charlie de toucher leur cible
alors ça fait des grosses fort mais
c'est un petit peu compliqué à suivre
tout ça du coup vous propose d'étudier
unis pendant le cas plus simple ou
charlie toujours fasciné c'est à dire c
est égal à un homme sarah dû pas mal les
équations donc ça nous donne cette
condition sur a et là on voit que si b
en fait
trop grand alors la première condition
ne peut pas être vérifié parce que le
terme de droite ici et va être négatif
en particulier ça c'est le cas lorsque b
est égal à 1,2 me dans le cas de sud du
bloc de j j
on avait les probabilités abc qui était
égale à un tiers un demi et un répit non
avenu vidéo de nos moeurs était un tiers
2/3 1
dans ces deux cas en fait la preuve
était de baies et de toucher sa cible
est trop grande pour que à et intérêts à
tirer sur charlie non ces deux cas à
lycéens tiré tiré en l'air mais si
jamais la priorité de bay est très
faible alors alice va avoir un terreau a
tiré directement sur charlie gros
effectivement ça correspond au fait que
de toute façon bob va rater sa cible que
du coup charles ives tué bob et ensuite
alice va voir un duel imposé contre
charlie même si c'est alice qui va avoir
la priorité
charlie va gagner immédiatement ce duel
vaut mieux se retrouver dans un duel à
ce moment là contre bob ou bob à la
priorité plutôt que de devoir affronter
charlie en duel c'est un petit peu
logique intuitive derrière tout ça donc
la formule exacte c'est ça qui est en
partie que l'on peut avoir un changement
de comportement d'alice lorsque b est
suffisamment faible et que a est plus
faible que cette quantité
j'espère que vous avez aimé cet épisode
la prochaine fois on va parler du prix
de l'anarchie petit à petit on va
revenir sur la politique
si vous avez aimé cet épisode penser à
le l'ikea le commentaire le partage et
pensez à vous abonner pour ne pas
manquer les futurs épisodes merci aux
tipa awards et j'espère que vous serez
là la prochaine fois et début 2015 cette
même équipe a poussé le bouchon beaucoup
plus loin puisque cette fois ils ont
résolu le jeu de poker dans cette
variante est en fuite
c'est à dire qu'ils ont publié un
nouveau programme qui s'appelle ces
foetus et qui lui est mathématiquement
imbattable que de même sexe